foreign
Louisville Kentucky hi Cindy welcome to
the Ramsey Show
pleasure to meet you
um your program really made a huge
difference for my family and it's it's
just been a big deal for for generations
of my family so thank you for that well
thank you how can we help
so my husband and I have been saving up
for a couple years he's been saving up
since before we got married and so have
I
um and we've got about a hundred
thousand dollars saved up
I have deferred some of my retirement
savings but he's doing the 15 he's
supposed to do because we want to uh buy
our first house
um we're currently running from a family
member and I've done a lot of the
repairs on that um so I'm fairly handy
there's a house that we're looking at
that is an old Victorian house you can
probably see where this is about to go
it's the bank owned property they're
asking about 250 000 for it and I think
it would be worth easily that if it were
fully repaired I think it'd be worth a
lot more
the problem is that it needs some
significant repairs and when I say
significant I mean probably needs to be
completely rewired
it still has old black metal pipes that
are going to have to get torn out
and obviously some of those go through
the walls which are old plaster walls
that could be a lot of work getting that
out the HVAC systems
have some obvious issues with the way
they've been wired in and installed
so my question really is
how much we should be willing to offer
it also my husband and I are expecting a
baby in February so I'm pretty handy
there are a lot of things I can do there
are a lot of things I can't do pregnant
or postpartum
the bank have a pretty pretty adamant
that they did not want to take less than
the 250 they were asking I think they're
getting that number personally based off
of uh property taxes were just
reassessed on it and shitty says that's
what the property taxes are
but um they weren't really willing to
come down on the property please please
please
walk away
nothing in you said in this entire
conversation sounds fun
that listen I've done historic rehabs
they don't build them like they used to
thank God
we have learned a lot about construction
techniques since 1916 and that's why we
don't put knob and tube wiring in things
and why we don't put those black pipes
in there and why we don't use plaster
anymore and why we don't and why we
don't and why we don't and why we don't
this is your very first house and your
very first rehab in your very first
series of things and you keep telling me
how handy you are you ain't that handy
yeah this is a disaster you ever seen
the movie Money Pit
you know I can't say I have well you
ought to go watch it it'll tell you not
to do this deal yes okay
please don't do this deal here's the
thing this sounds cute and you're
looking for a deal and you're willing to
do some repairs and you're signing up
for 10 to 15 x what you think you're
signing up for in hassle in unknowns
it's almost impossible to run an
accurate estimate on the rehab because
every time you open up a wall there's
another dadgum mess in that wall
yeah and you can't have to do a plaster
you get one shot the whole wall or
nothing
you can't patch plaster
you can patch drywall
you can't patch plaster
you can tell it it's you know there's a
there's no technique that does this so
you take the whole wall off and then you
get to do the whole wall back and oh God
it's you know if you want to do that you
need to be an experienced rehabber that
knows something about historic
Renovations this is a massive project
let me just tell you if you want to
build a home from the ground up it would
be 10x easier than the project you're
talking about and I've done lots of both
lots of both I actually know what I'm
talking about
yeah I definitely appreciate that yeah
do not do this deal
the bank is too high they're out of
their dadgum mines you're pregnant and
the last thing you need is another child
that's a that's a problem child house
yeah Cindy I think you need a new vision
I think you've had a great vision for
this you guys have looked at this oh
your vision got your vision got uh uh
kidnapped yeah you know by this one
stupid house because it's it's so cute
and ginger pretty and looks like it
could be so cool on the Outside Inside
is Hell on Earth yeah it's a great
vision but not a great decision you know
that's the issue you can do this
somewhere else hold walk away on this
deal and find another thing that's a
much better deal where you can let that
Vision kind of go but that's that's what
they're wrestling with yeah you're gonna
have to strip every wall and come back
with every single piece of Plumbing
every Plumbing fixture every piece of
wiring every plug the the the main the
electrical main the water main all have
to be replaced everything in there or
you're never gonna get it right you
can't patch this because the the system
is bad and it's ancient yeah
I think that we when we were talking
about it originally we're like if we
were gonna do it if we were going to be
able to pull this off the only way we
could do it is really to take it you
know first floor and get the first floor
functional and then over the course of a
couple years get that second job you
can't stop you can I
really really
reattach the place which is the problem
yeah that's a problem you're getting
ready to pay too much and you're
underestimating your costs and you're
underestimating the emotional pain it's
going to take to finish this project
dramatically
dramatically Cindy not just a little bit
Cindy dramatically I don't hate
historics I hate historics as your first
rehab I hate historics being done by a
woman who just had her first baby I hate
historics for the first home you ever
own in your life oh it's like buying a
car out behind some Old Farmer's house
that's rusted and you're going to take
it all the way down to the frame and
you're going to build it back with your
bare freaking hands and end up with a
car when you're done that's not as good
as a new car
s are the same way I love old cars but
they don't build them like they used to
thank God
we got these new things called disc
brakes they're amazing you know oh geez
this is the Ramsay show